once upon a time in my not so distant
past I had a stalker this is that story
okay so as you can see or not see I
guess I'm going to be anonymous for this
video this was a pretty scary time for
me so I think it's just best if we do it
this way here we go so one day I'm
eating at this restaurant and this guy
comes up to me have you ever thought
about modeling he asks and we get to
talking whatever image you have in your
head of this person you're probably
right
two words sunglasses inside let's call
him John he explains that he works for a
local modeling agency he shows me their
website looks legit and he says that I
should think about joining to be honest
modeling was something I had always
considered pursuing so I decided to hear
him out after all isn't this how people
get discovered in my head I'm thinking
even if this guy isn't legitimate plain
and simple I just don't work with him
John doesn't have a business card so he
asks for my number harmless enough I
think so
I gave it to him we'll be in touch he
says and then he leaves a few days go by
and via text we arranged to meet up
again to talk about the specifics for
how this whole modeling thing would work
okay this is where things start to get a
little bit strange we meet in a coffee
shop I sit down and I see a stack of
papers sitting next to him okay so to
get started we'll need to get you a comp
card no professional model can show up
to a casting without a comp card I can
set you up with a photographer bla bla
bla bla for those of you who are
unfamiliar with the modeling world a
comp card is basically a models business
card to quickly backtrack to anyone who
is watching who's like what are you
doing get out of there I did do some
research beforehand
apparently there's a common scam for
models where someone says they'll make
you a comp card but then the
photographer will charge you a bunch of
money for the pictures so in my head I'm
thinking
I know what's going on here if they need
photos for me I can just get a
photographer friend to take them for
free actually you know what he says
suddenly there's a casting call for a
shoot right now we should definitely go
I'm like no I can't right now
talking my way out of it all so I didn't
even have a comp card yet
John was already contradicting himself
okay well here's a contract you can go
ahead and sign it and we'll just look
for more casting calls I look over the
papers my name is already filled into
the contract and it's spelled wrong not
to mention it's a two-year contract and
to top it all off the name of the agency
was completely different than the name
he originally told me my bad vibes meter
is off the charts I just need to get out
of there I explained that all the info
is wrong we can't do this right now
I try to leave but he keeps pressuring
me about this contract I'll send you a
fixed version what's your address I give
him my email know your address
okay so at this point in my life I was
doing a lot of freelance work that
involved invoices so I was constantly
giving people my address to send checks
to so you know up to this point I was
just like you can have my address and
you can have my address everyone can
have my address so I did it
I gave him my address I leave the coffee
shop I go home and I look at the company
that was on the contract the website is
so bad like comically bad I send the URL
to a friend of mine who is actually a
model and she basically tells me to
never talk to this guy ever again I was
officially done with seeing where this
goes over the next few days I'd get a
few texts from John trying to schedule a
time to get my comp card pictures taken
I don't respond at first but he keeps
contacting me I say that I'm sick and
that I won't be able to do it right now
enter a new
character in the story we should call
her Diana I start to get emails from
Diana she works for this agency they
need my measurements and are asking when
I can get started I don't answer any of
these I'm just trying to distance myself
thinking that maybe they lose interest
in me about a week goes by I get a
photographer friend to take pictures of
me for my own comp car I actually don't
hear from John or Diana for a few days
okay finally some breathing room here
one day I'm home alone hanging in my
apartment just watching TV suddenly
there's a noise coming from the front
door like someone's trying to open it no
knocking just the turning of the
doorknob I freeze someone is trying to
get into my apartment my heart is
pounding my eyes are glued to the front
door after what feels like an eternity
that noise stops I think they're gone
but then I hear a slow quiet rustling a
single sheet of paper is being slid
under the door I hear the person walk
away and they're gone I could barely
move but I eventually summon up the
courage to go pick up the paper it's a
sheet of like notebook paper and on it
is a handwritten note
it's from the agency and it's how they
haven't heard from me in a while and
need to get in contact with me so we can
book more modeling gigs and stop losing
money
this has 1,000% gone too far I wait a
little while and then I decide that I'm
gonna text John I don't work for you
please leave me alone
he acts like nothing happened he jumps
right into other casting calls and how I
still need a car
enough with the cop car I tell him my
friend already took pictures of me stop
contacting me in the meantime I needed
to tell my roommates what was happening
within a day or two my photographer
friend gets an email
it's from a completely new person so I
guess we can just call her Regina to
paraphrase the email says leave my name
alone are you kidding me
I have no idea how they got my friend's
email or why they told her to leave me
alone now I'm getting really mad leave
my friend out of this I'd never had nor
ever will work for you I have almost no
doubt that John is behind all of these
emails and every time I would stand up
to him it seemed that a new fake person
would just pop up days go by I'd be home
with my roommates and there would be
random knocks on our front door we were
scared to get our mail or even take out
the trash to be honest I was scared to
walk alone at night
I eventually receive an email from John
telling me I'm fired he also told me to
stop contacting him I for one have never
been fired from a job that I never
worked at so that was a first in the
meantime I finally decided to tell my
mom I was hesitant to up to this point
because I knew that she wouldn't take it
lightly I kept a lot of this to myself
because it was confusing
maybe a little bit embarrassing and
above all really scary
I needed a support system to beat this
guy so I tell my mom and of course she's
freaking out and is like we me to report
him I'm still getting emails from John
and Diana tell
that unfired in fact this was literally
everyday okay now this last part of the
story gets a little confusing if you
weren't already confused enough one day
I get a new email from this girl Regina
if you can't keep track this is the girl
who told my friend to leave me alone the
email says if someone named John
harassing you because it's happening to
me too and I think we should work
together to stop this wait what I answer
by saying I want to believe you but I
don't she tells me that John is using
her identity to harass other people with
fake emails she also tells me that John
isn't even his real name to her he was
going by a completely different name
between John fake John Diana make Regina
I don't even know who to believe but she
tells me she'll prove that she's real
via a video call I decided to take her
up on it and it turns out she is real
just a regular person like me who got
caught up in some weird entertainment
scam she was so nice and we actually got
to bond over how crazy this whole
experience is we both agreed to contact
the police and stop this once and for
all the next day or so after talking
with real Regina my friends and my
family I take my story to the police you
can't see my face right now but I am
rolling my eyes they weren't able to do
anything nothing I tell them about the
emails the texts the coming to my
apartment well he never came into your
apartment so there's nothing weak
do what do you want me to invite him
inside for tea to be honest I was pretty
defeated by this I thought I had this
figured out but they wouldn't even
listen to my full story a few days go by
my roommates and I are still on high
alert especially after not getting any
help from the police one day my roommate
is taking out her laundry to the
laundromat she closes the front door
behind her and notices a parked car
outside of our apartment building
there's two men in the car now I had
told my roommates what John looks like
so that they would know what to look out
for it was him it was John he was in the
car parked outside of our apartment with
another random person by his side
thankfully my roommate immediately
recognizes him drops her laundry and
whips out her phone to try to get a
picture of his license plate they notice
what she's doing and then they speed off
after that I never heard a single thing
from him again not from him not from
Diana not from fake Regina nothing to
anyone who's worried I've since moved
apartments and I'm feeling safe again
did I think any of this terrifying stuff
was going to happen to me of course
did I make some mistakes along the way
absolutely was it my fault though during
the beginning of this whole experience I
didn't really take it seriously I
thought I could just ignore it enough
for it to go away and it ended up
turning into something that put myself
my friends my roommates and my family at
risk I've always been a very independent
person rarely asking for help or rarely
admitting when I feel unsafe or scared
it took a lot for me to admit those
feelings and tell others would have
happened to anyone who's watching this
please be careful watch out for yourself
and if you ever find yourself in a
similar situation please tell someone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]